so one of the common questions I get
from friends family or some people on
LinkedIn is Pat how come I don't have a
great job I don't like my job and I get
this message over and over and over
again so today's episode is dedicated to
your entrepreneurs you may want to watch
this and share it with the employees
that work for you or somebody that said
that's you so let me get right into it
ten reasons why you don't have a great
job so step number one before we get
into it it's a very simple relationship
that everybody needs to know who has a
job if the employer is happy with you
and the employee is happy with the
employer everyone's happy
there is no friction unfortunately a lot
of times people say I hate my job just
know that the employer is probably
feeling the same way about you as well
that's not typically a one-way thing
it's typically a two-sided thing so why
does this typically happen I think a lot
of times people don't even know what
they're looking for it's almost like
you're looking for a boyfriend or
girlfriend and you are clueless so no
matter who you date you're going to be
miserable you're not going to like them
and it has nothing to do with him or her
you don't know what you want so step
number one and looking for a job is
solve for X what is an ideal position
for you and what is the priority of this
position for you for instance you may
say benefit I need great benefits why my
wife is taking certain medication and I
need to have great benefits because she
needs to be on well I have three kids
whatever it is benefits may be for you
at baby income I just need an income
this is all I'm looking for is this
income I'm looking for 70 grand you and
that's it I don't care about anything
else I need a solid income three
long-term I want to find a job that I
can grow within the company number four
experience I want to get into this
industry I want to get some experience
under my belt you know yesterday I sit
with a guy here who does audits for big
companies we're going through some
things right now
so they audit to have audited financials
so if you ever go public or you're
required you have audited financials I
said how'd you start off your career I
started off with one of the big four
accounting firms and that's how I
started my career and then I went and
started or I went and started with a CPA
I want to join the company I got an
equity part of it and I've been doing
that for the last 13 years from Portland
Oregon phenomenal but he went for
experience first or you're solving
connections I want context I want to
work at Google because I want contacts
to engineers etc etc or its passion I
just want to do pen I want to go out
there and make songs I want to go out
there and edit I want to go out there
into its passion or it could be a
location I want to be close to my kids
that's what I'm solving for I don't want
to move to LA I want to go to New York I
want my family to be here there's a
location that matters as a number one
reasoning supplemental income you want
secondary income next one could be
companionship what is companionship
there are people that work at uber and
they just drive over just because they
want to talk to you because they don't
have anybody else to talk to they're
living in City they know nobody
so they drive for four hours just to
make some friends there are some old
people that work at Starbucks seventy
years old just to greet people just to
talk to people same as Walmart or last
but not least honor service so step
number one for you for getting a great
job is answer these questions what is
that the top hole is number one and they
go number two and number three by the
way any questions thoughts comments
about what I've said so far post it on
the bottom and if you haven't yet
subscribed to this channel click on that
subscribe button right here so you're a
subscriber on value can become a value
painter
number two so this is what you're
looking for number two what is the
current unemployment rate than where you
live but I hate my job
you may have a great job and you don't
even know it because the unemployment
sucks and there's a lot of people that
don't have jobs
so if unemployment is above six seven to
ten percent or higher you can't be too
choosy if unemployment is zero to six
percent zero to five percent you can be
choosy because there is jobs out there
the markets open they can give you
opportunities you can look for things
and then the other thing for you to be
looking for is what you offer in a
marketplace what do you truly offer like
remember happy happy if this is happy
employer employers up everybody goes
unhappy what do you offer what is it
what is your proposition to the employer
what skill said you have what expertise
you have what experience do you have
what context you bring to the table what
attitude how was your attitude like it's
an attitude that you come in and you
completely change the life of the office
or a life of the company because you're
synergist you make people feel good you
bring people together a evert
hard-working
maybe you're coachable you're very good
Souter you're always wanting to learn
you're a degree you've got a degree in
this specific job so your experience
creativity you have a creative mind and
people talk about your level of
creativity so people know that you're
following your influence maybe you got a
big you know social media presence and
you have marketing skills and SEO and
all this other stuff so your influence
part of your connections but it's also
your influence that can help the company
out so once you do that and then see the
current demand for your position has
somebody that came up to me and they
said hey Pat I think I'm worth 80 I said
oh really what position such-and-such
position I want to do my research the
paying position for that was 60 grandeur
I said thing you need to do a little bit
more research on what that position pays
for especially with your experience when
came back I said what did you find about
$60,000 I said that's for what I'm
comfortable paying you I'm not
comfortable paying you more than that if
you think you're worth more than I keep
looking if not I'll tell you 60 okay
I'll take the 60 took the 60 so you've
got to know what it is also you're at so
once you know those things okay
happy happy here solve for X here the
current unemployment rate in whatever
country you're living in what you're
offering to the company and what your
position is what is the demand for your
position then we talk about ten reasons
why people can't get a job although most
people don't even do what I just talked
to you about now let me give up at ten
reasons why you don't have a great job
number one you get around let me tell
you what is getting around so look men
and women don't want to date a partner
that's been way too promiscuous now some
of us are forgiven but let's just say if
you're watching this and you're saying
what path that's not fair and that's
this is if you've been a little too
promiscuous neither partner can really
fully trust everything's okay what
happened here man you know reputation is
this the same as hiring somebody for the
company if you've been around and you
have 20 jobs in the last three years I
mean there's a problem there there's a
trend there you can't sit there and say
there's not a problem there so sometimes
I'll get a resume and there'll be a big
gap okay
there'll be a gap and then when we call
references eventually you'll figure out
that this person had jobs but there were
only two weeks jobs that didn't work out
that they didn't put in the resume so
they really had six additional jobs on
the last two years
people don't want employers don't want
to hire
people that get around because they can
there think about it this way I'm going
to put six months or 60 days of training
into this guy for him to quit three
months later so wasting my money why am
i doing that they don't like that that's
why you may not get a great job number
two you oversell yourself at Samba as
somebody I hired I give it to this girl
for the way she did the interview in the
interview I thought she was Oprah
Winfrey okay by the time this interview
was done she was like well you know I
can do this I can do not know everything
about SEO I know everything about this
this WordPress I know everything Wow
she's using all those words though I'm a
solution oriented type of a person and
yet I want you to know I always bring
the solution to you I don't bring the
problem I'm a team player all these
things like bullet points bam bam bam
bam bam all these things you want to
hear she said it and it's okay let's
call some of the references couple of
them didn't call us back one called us
back and one which okay let's give this
person a shot she got hired the next day
none of those things were true she never
brought solutions always problems she
always complained in this list one by
the way this was a couple years ago so
this is not a recent thing but if you
already sell yourself in an interview
and then you fall short
you're fired like this no matter where
you work at so you need to make sure
you're not over selling yourself in an
interview number three lack of
flexibility if you want a great job and
you want to work at a company that's got
long-term benefits and they're going
places there's a part of me that's got
to be flexible if you're not too
flexible you're too rigid then what
you're saying is you're really only
solving for income and by the way I'm in
the insurance industry there's a lot of
big insurance companies that hire people
based on income and it doesn't mean to
be flexibility because it's just here's
what you're going to do you don't really
care for the company you don't love the
job it's just you need it the income so
you're willing to take it that company
also knows what they got you if they
wanted to fire you in two years they can
fire you like this so there's not no
deep-rooted relationship passion for the
company nothing like that right so
understand over selling yourself and
lack of flexibility that could hurt your
long-term if you want that great job
number four attitude attitude goes a
long way there isn't enough videos in
the world and enough books in a world of
attitude because the value of AD
- it's so high it's insane how high the
value of attitude is I'm here to tell
you the guy on social media who's the
guy that's blown up with his YouTube
channel what's his name Logan Paul Logan
Paul that's got 7 8 million views by the
time you watch it we may have 10 11
million views people love him because of
his attitude he's got an awesome
attitude it's so attractive people love
great attitudes maybe you have an
attitude that's so positive people want
to be around it right next to cool for
school until what I mean by too cool for
school so I had somebody that I hired
this was a six-figure salary person I
hired I hired somebody who is a
six-figure salary but he was too cool to
learn okay there was nothing about it
that was wanting to learn how to do this
learn how to do that he was too cool for
school way too cool for school so you
don't want to learn new skills he didn't
want to learn anything new he was still
in his dass you know those I still use
my blackberry and they barely you know
adapting to social media obviously I'm
being sarcastic but you understand my
point you they are too cool for school
and those people are too cool for school
you cannot stay with a great job because
what a great job really is telling you
is it's a company that's constantly
adapting and improving and a company
that's constantly improving which makes
it a great job requires you to
constantly improving your skill set to
stay trendy if you don't you are not
going to keep a great job because the
employer is not happy number six effort
very simple you bring effort great I had
a person in an interview say I'm the
type of person that always shows up 15
minutes early 50 if you're on time
you're too late all these lines right
every single day for the first week of
employment she was late 10 minutes every
day she was late 10 minutes and it was
always dogs not feeling good he threw up
all night no kid wasn't feeling too good
the other time was car broke down the
traffic was bad and there was a car
accident five days straight every one of
them another like so what are you going
to use next week I'm really curious and
I really want to hear next week Cowboys
lost I mean what is it going to be it
was too big of a party in a riot or
protesting I'm just curious what's
coming next
point being effort if there's effort
you'll typically land a great job
there's not effort these types of
companies demand hard work because they
have bigger dreams and bigger goals
number seven social media presence let
me explain to what it is about social
media presence when you hire a company I
am very lucky that social media didn't
exist when I was 18 years old I'm
telling you right now it was a big
blessing because if Instagram and
snapchat was run when I was 18 nobody
would hire me if social media was around
when I was 18 years old having said that
for you there social media which means
what you got to be careful so that
picture with the beer bong you can't
have on there okay you're linkedin's got
to be a professional pic if you don't
want to wear a suit and a tie we're a
professional attire and a decent haircut
you know don't don't put your you know
haircut that's just like the curly hair
coming out like a Superman curl you got
going on here none of that stuff very
professional picture you put on LinkedIn
businesses will typically look at
LinkedIn first but they're going to
scope out everything else so have a
solid social media presence number eight
you're begging and it's obvious great
companies don't hire beggars let me tell
you they don't hire beggars I know this
sounds strange strange but it's kind of
like this the prettiest girl you want to
date you think she's turned on by
beggars hell no she wants a guy that's
like you know who I am
we're going out together and we're gonna
have a good time I'm gonna show you a
good time hey please go on a date with
me please go on a date with me please go
on a date with me that's begging if you
really want a great job and you present
yourself properly that doesn't mean you
can't be creative that doesn't mean you
can't be aggressive and assertive not
necessary to aggressive but somewhat
assertive that doesn't mean you can't do
that but it's not I'm coming in here
because only this you're going to say I
just want you to know I'm very happy if
I get the position work for your company
but I just want you to know I promise
you you are going to be very glad you
made the decision to hire me and you'll
find that out within the first 90 days
of me working for you that that's like
I'm not begging Richard just please give
me an opportunity please I beg you just
please give me a chance to work for your
company they're not hiring you somes
missing here and companies hire
confident people number nine unemployed
too long if you're unemployed too long
red flag if you haven't had a job for
way too long there's a problem right
there in ten last finales endorsements
you know if
you have people saying good things about
you your references or weak references
if you have solid references you'll have
an opportunity because we call
references everybody that we have we
call every single reference and we try
to talk to them before we give the
person a second or third interview so
it's important who your references are
and by the way reference calls if they
just say the typical thing and you prep
somebody everybody typically knows like
you got to realize once you do 200
reference calls you know whose reference
calls are fake so you can't put a fake
reference call because the first thing a
person is doing is going on the
references linked in to see who this
person is and then sending a message
there and saying do you know this can
you get on the phone because we'd like
to do a reference check they're checking
the credibility on the individual as
well and so you gotta have some solid
references if you do if somebody puts a
good word in for you great if somebody
contacts the reference and they present
you properly because you've done a good
job with them that benefits you as well
so having said that these are ten
reasons why somebody doesn't get have a
great job and if you're watching this
questions thoughts comments put them on
the bottom but if you're watching this
you know somebody who needs to watch
this share it with them if it is you go
back assess yourself here assess your
market hear your offer here write it
down the position you want write it down
one of these 10 see which one that needs
improvement improvement in then go get
that great job that you're looking for
would that be in sense I have a great
able body take care
[Music]